on passe justement puisqu'on parlait de
la fausse rumeur c'est le petit benoît
dumas qu'on adore voyez benoît secret
story cas gagner secret story 4 que
j'adore et donc il fait un magasin
magnéto chaque semaine ça s'appelle
fausses rumeurs il va dans la rue
il montre des rumeurs à des gens et on
voit si belle réaction regarder salut
les amis aujourd'hui j'ai préparé des
fausses couvertures de magazines people
je vais les proposer au public on va
voir ce qu'ils en pensent
suivez-moi
[Musique]
alors on a des couvertures de presse qui
vont sortir en avant première qu'en
penses tu non c'est pas possible ça
[Rires]
si geneviève geneviève de fontenay ses
photos sexy
ça y est enfin non mais c'est pas elle
sait pas mc je vous dis que c'est elle
je pense que cette couverture genre elle
avec un renault est mal noté m tant
mieux ou tant mieux mais je suis là un
peu la vieille rahway mais là la vieille
après un coup les renois et oui et alors
merci mur
[Musique]
c'est bien que si matthew blacks
tous les blocs de la capitale faites
attention à vous marine le pen est dans
le coin mimie mathy elle se rend
complexe et bien le père son cousin son
cousin français une joue la sextape de
michel drucker qu'est ce que j'en pense
alors je les ai vus et contrairement à
ce que je pensais il ya beaucoup de
rythme je m'attendais à ce qu'ils aient
monde rythme que ça c'est vrai et c'est
assez rythmé chaussures légende façon
c'est un foie gras le gain de temps
c'est qu'il a un peu fou fou qu'on
scooter mimie mathy elle a refait sa vie
avec julien lepers j'adore si j'avais
une chance voilà mimie mathy 0,6
complètement privé sont déroulés
[Musique]
ce petit benoît bala c'est très drôle
c'est très bien